se sabía que esta venta cautivaría a los
aficionados al arte de todo el mundo
el lote número 12 es el siguiente y
estamos por supuesto muy emocionados de
ofrecer este autorretrato de frida kahlo
de 1949 diego y yo el último
autorretrato íntegramente realizado por
la artista antes de su muerte en 1954 el
cuadro muestra los ojos de frida kahlo
con lágrimas y parte de su rostro
cubierto por su marido 'diego rivera' la
pintura simboliza su tormentosa relación
la pareja estuvo casada durante casi 25
años en un matrimonio apasionado y
turbulento la obra mide sólo 30 x 22.4
centímetros y es la primera vez que
aparece en el mercado del arte en más de
30 años por lo que tan pronto como se
inició la subasta fue un éxito
y en menos de un minuto
por 31 millones de dólares última
oportunidad la oferta de anna por 31
millones de dólares
el valor total de casi 35 millones de
dólares que incluye los honorarios la
convierte en la obra de arte más cara de
un artista latinoamericano jamás vendida
en una subasta